Team USA is now two wins away from
repeating has Women's World Cup
champions the American women Delta
knockout blow to the host nation of
France in Paris yesterday they will face
England on Tuesday for a spot in the
final two of the remaining four spots in
the semi finals will be decided today
but in last night's game Team USA's most
in the News player made her presence
felt Roxana Saberi is in Paris outside
the stadium where that came to a place
Roxana good morning good morning around
45,000 people packed the stadium here
last night to watch a game that was fast
paced and intense it was also a game
that put the power of women's soccer on
full display
in a stadium throbbing with red white
and blue team USA took on its toughest
test yet in this tournament rising
soccer superpower France just five
minutes in who captain Megan Rapinoe
stepped up to the challenge
France pushed back hard but 60 minutes
later that Rapinoe scored again soon
after France replied with the final
whistle its dreams were crushed everyone
you know understands the gravity of the
night playing the host and one of the
favorites in a beautiful Stadium in
Paris I mean it's just phenomenal while
Rapinoe stole the spotlight last night
she also made headlines this week when
her pledge not to visit the White House
if her team wins the World Cup sparked a
criticism from President Trump she
insisted her team was still focused on
the field that it was in magnifique sis
wha it's everything you want obviously
we're not at a home World Cup so a good
healthy hostile crowd our fans were
amazing they screamed their little
hearts out did you ever have any doubt
that they might not win you know there
were moments where you're just kinda you
know it could go either way in many ways
it was a glorious game for both sides
confirming the growth of women's soccer
at its widespread appeal around the
world and among Americans what does this
team mean to you
this team is gives us a chance to
actually be champions but first it has
to win those next two games here in
France its semi-final against England is
bound to be another tough match data all
right